[Musique]
j'écoute mais c'est conforme non stop
service je ne crois pas trop tôt pour
moi bon client pour bordeaux alors ne
quitte pas je donne un imac entrons
l'animent control j'ai un client
destination de bordeaux ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un est intéressé
jolie oui d'accord lorsqu'on arrive dans
de l'eau si vous changez dans sa cuisine
et le gast appel lancé il ya une semaine
à nîmes par air inter cette nouvelle
formule avions stop service est
uniquement sur simple demande de votre
part le responsable du guichet d'avion
stop service appel par l'intermédiaire
de contrôler les nombreux avions de
ligne survolant la région le commandant
de bord intéressés par la course parce
qu'il va plus ou moins dans votre
direction
vous allez dans son avion ou charge en
bout de piste et redécollent aussitôt
ainsi avec acision stop services plus
d'attentes inutiles aux aéroports pour
nous ça s'est très bien passé nous ça ne
crée pas de charges supplémentaires et
nous avons fait jusqu'à présent une
vingtaine de chargement par jour
pourquoi il ya combien d'avions qui
survole nîmes chaque jour entre 2005 et
3000 réaction des commandeurs mercure
d'air inter ce que généralement vous
voler au dessus des nuages jeudi plus de
10000 m oui alors avec cette nouvelle
formule sera pas mis en service la
compagnie vous fait voler à combien en
bas quelques dizaines de mètres c'est
agréable vous avez le temps de voir un
petit peu le paysage on your des nuages
où on veut la partager ce constat les
passagers oui surpris les comptes en
levant vous apprenez beaucoup dans la
journée comme ça des clients à
aujourd'hui où ça fait le septième ou
est alors qu'en france on arrête là de
paul et que derrière alors ils
continueront mais vous êtes obligés de
les prendre à jacques brel
ah non ça dépend un peu ma direction
c'est vous qui les fait payer à bord oui
bien sûr bon allez on parle pas depuis
une semaine qu'on a commencé on a fait
un jour
on s'est posé cette fois oui alors
évidemment au début il croyait partie à
hambourg arrivé directement à
destination avant il avait cet
atterrissage mais oh
en résumé ils sont pas trop mécontent et
les prévenir quoi voyez vous posez l'ag
de clients qu'il faudrait sur les
tendances de peaux doit maintenant y'en
a marre de l'eau non non pas du soir
maintenant c'est trop tard
si cette nouvelle formule vous intéresse
écrivez nous avions sauf services
fr3 11 rue françois 1er paris 8e
[Musique]